avec qui ils peuvent être ?
Vous n'avez pas ce pouvoir.
Personne n'a le pouvoir de dire : « Vous ne pouvez pas épouser cette demoiselle »
Qui a ce pouvoir ? Personne.
SM : Mais vous savez quoi ?
Notre État a mis ce pouvoir entre vos mains,
et ce que vous devez faire
c'est voter, vous allez voter pour la 6.
H2 : Je comprends.
SM : Votez pour la 6, d'accord ? H2 : Je comprends.
KSM : Eh bien, avez-vous tous besoin d'heures de travaux d'intérêts généraux ?
Oui ? Vous pouvez vous porter volontaire pour travailler avec nous
et faire des heures de travaux d'intérêts généraux.
Vous voulez tous faire ça ?
On vous nourrit. On vous amène de la pizza.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Yoruba Richen : Merci.
Ce que je trouve étonnant dans cette vidéo
que nous avons prise juste pendant que nous filmions,
c'est qu'elle montre à quel point Karess
comprend l'historique du mouvement pour les droits civiques,
mais elle s'y limite pas.
Elle ne s'arrête pas aux personnes noires.
Elle le voit comme un plan
pour étendre les droits des gays et des lesbiennes.
Peut-être parce qu'elle est plus jeune, elle a environ 25 ans,
elle est capable de le faire un peu plus aisément,
mais le fait est que les électeurs du Maryland
ont fait passé l'amendement pour l'égalité du mariage,
et en fait, c'était la première fois
que l'égalité du mariage était votée
et validée directement par les électeurs.
Les afro-américains l'ont soutenu à un niveau plus élevé
que quoi que ce soit auparavant.
C'était un complet renversement de situation par rapport à cette nuit
de 2008 où la Proposition 8 était passée.
C'était monumental et on le ressentait.
Nous, dans la communauté LGBT, sommes passés
d'un groupe dit malade et insulté
et dit criminel
à être vu comme une partie de la grande quête humaine
pour la dignité et l'égalité.
Nous sommes passés de devoir cacher notre sexualité
pour garder notre travail et notre famille
à avoir littéralement notre place à table
avec le président
et à être apostrophés lors de sa seconde inauguration.
Je voudrais juste lire ce qu'il a dit
à cette inauguration :
« Nous, le peuple, déclarons aujourd'hui
la vérité la plus évidente :
nous sommes tous créés égaux.
Ce sont toujours les étoiles qui nous guident,
comme elles l'ont fait avec nos ancêtres
à travers Seneca Falls,
Selma et Stonewall. »
Nous savons que tout n'est pas parfait,
particulièrement lorsque l'on regarde ce qu'il se passe
à l'international en ce qui concerne les droits de la communauté LGBT,
mais ça dit quelque chose sur jusqu'où nous sommes allés
quand notre président place la lutte homosexuelle
à la même échelle que les autres grandes luttes pour la liberté
de notre époque : le mouvement pour les droits des femmes
et le mouvement pour les droits civiques.
Sa déclaration montre non seulement
que ces mouvements sont interconnectés
mais aussi comment chacun a emprunté
et été inspiré par l'autre.
Comme Martin Luther King
a appris et emprunté des tactiques de Gandhi
sur la désobéissance civile et la non-violence,
qui sont devenus des fondements du mouvement pour les droits civiques,
le mouvement pour les droits des homosexuels a vu ça fonctionner
pour le mouvement pour les droits civiques,
et a utilisé certaines de ces stratégies
et tactiques pour avancer
à un rythme encore plus rapide.
Peut-être une autre raison
du progrès relativement rapide
du mouvement pour les droits des gays.
Alors que beaucoup d'entre nous continuent à vivre
dans des endroits où il y a de la ségrégation raciale,
les personnes de la communauté LGBT sont partout.
Nous sommes dans les communautés urbaines
et dans les communautés rurales,
dans celles de couleur et de l'immigration,
dans les églises, les mosquées et les synagogues.
Nous sommes vos mères, frères,
sœurs et fils.
Quand quelqu'un que vous aimez
ou un membre de votre famille fait son coming-out,
peut-être est-ce plus facile de supporter sa quête pour l'égalité.
En fait, le mouvement pour les droits des homosexuels
nous demande de soutenir la justice et l'égalité
depuis un espace d'amour.
C'est peut-être le plus grand et le meilleur cadeau
que le mouvement nous ait donné.
Il nous appelle à accéder à la chose la plus universelle
et la plus intime :
l'amour de notre frère, de notre sœur
et de notre voisin.
Je voudrais juste finir avec une citation
d'un des plus grands combattants pour la liberté
qui n'est plus parmi nous aujourd'hui, Nelson Mandela
de l'Afrique du Sud.
Nelson Mandela a dirigé l'Afrique du Sud
après les jours sombres et violents de l'apartheid,
et à partir des cendres de cette discrimination raciale légalisée,
il a mené l'Afrique du Sud à être le premier pays
du monde à bannir de sa constitution
la discrimination basée sur l'orientation sexuelle.
Mandela a dit :
« Être libre, ce n'est pas seulement se débarrasser de ses chaînes,
c'est vivre d'une façon qui respecte
et renforce la liberté des autres. »
Alors que ces mouvements continuent
et que les luttes pour la liberté continuent à travers le monde,
souvenons-nous qu'elles ne sont pas seulement interconnectées,
mais qu'elles doivent se soutenir et se mettre en valeur entre elles
afin que nous soyons réellement les vainqueurs.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)